el ex presidente estadounidense donald
trump no puede impedir que los
investigadores del asalto al capitolio
accedan a los registros de la casa
blanca así lo ha decidido este martes un
tribunal federal tras los esfuerzos de
trump por blindar los documentos sobre
sus actuaciones el 6 de enero y después
de que el actual presidente joe biden
entregara el material al consejo un
debate que se reduce a un poder
presidencial llamado privilegio
ejecutivo pero que la jueza dictaminó ya
no aplica contra los presidentes no son
reyes y el demandante no es el
presidente es una victoria para los
investigadores del congreso que esperan
determinar qué grado de responsabilidad
tiene trump en la incitación a la
insurrección el ex presidente apeló
inmediatamente la decisión del tribunal
pero los registros se entregarán el
viernes por la tarde a menos que
intervenga otro tribunal el comité de
investigación del congreso también ha
emitido citaciones a otras diez personas
cercanas a trump en busca de documentos
y testimonios la lista incluye a su ex
asesor principal stephen miller a la ex
secretaria de prensa nani y a otros
funcionarios de la casa blanca los
contratiempos legales no han cambiado el
discurso de trump de robo de las
elecciones de 2020 algo que volvió a
firmar el martes